it's a weekday night in Shenzhen
[Music]
the good citizens of the PRC have come
to this part to get fitter happier and
more productive
all under the watchful approving gaze of
Deng Xiaoping the revered granddaddy of
China's free market reforms
[Music]
the scene tells you much of what you
need to know about Shenzhen it's China
for sure but it's also something
different it's a city of imports young
hard-working smart and often freer
thinking people plucks from all around
the country
they've come here to toil during the day
improve themselves at night
and to get ahead its ambition that is
the lifeblood of Xinjiang its factories
its markets it startups it's surging
tech empires and it's stuff like this an
orgy astok explosion of LEDs that are
the greener and of course more
futuristic version of fireworks
[Music]
if your city do that no you City sure
[ __ ] can't but here's the story of why
Shenzhen can and why everyone especially
the folks in Silicon Valley should be
aware and probably a little frightened
of what's coming for them you get in the
metal tube
zoom up 115 floors at a ridiculous speed
to the top of the ping and skyscraper
[Music]
then you find a window and marvel at the
sublime bigness of Shenzhen
[Music]
forty years ago all this was farmland
and dirt roads a minor hub for rural
Goods trading just across the border
from Hong Kong now it's the hot steamy
frenetic home to 13 million people that
just about everyone on earth calls the
Silicon Valley of China everything here
moves at what's known as Shenzhen speed
it's a phrase that describes an
unyielding pace of change and I came
here to feel it firsthand
to do that
it's an Instagram pose with the
cityscape a quick scan for government
spy drones
and then a car I see we're just about
everything we use gets made you hear
about factories in China all the time
today I'm lucky enough to actually go
visit one that's located about an hour
outside of the center of the city
they're gonna let us see what life is
like inside one of these factories there
are grim factories there are decent
factories and then there's this place
run by grants and electronic it's safe
to say this is not what I expected
the plush surroundings are intended to
make customers from all parts of the
world feel comfortable but inside it's
more like you'd expect dozens of workers
moving at Schengen speed making fancy
headphones for an Australian company
called Nura how did you guys end up in
Shenzhen I guess that's the thing to do
these days
yeah ginger is knowing there's a place
that people come to to make things yep
you don't come here to mess around you
come here to get things done they have
the supply chain here a supplier that
can make any component the headphones
you need and of course there's the labor
costs which is no cheap as used to be
but still reasonable the production line
has been running at basically maximum
capacity since we started and yeah we
can do 500 a day Norman what are the
little noises we hear in the background
you're hearing them make sure they
assemble the speaker correctly so that's
a good test boys yeah that's right okay
but what is life like for the people who
make these wonderful toys to get a taste
of the factory experience I joined the
mad dash for lunch
hmm cafeteria food
how's that food it's good how long have
you worked here okay it's tough to say
anything terribly new about the life of
the Chinese factory worker most of these
people have come from China's
hinterlands often leaving their families
behind in their rural hometowns they'll
spend about two years on average in
Shenzhen busting their butts working
overtime to save up as much money as
they can
is it a step up from hardscrabble
subsistence farming probably are there
still safety nets yep but I can tell you
one major lifestyle advantage the
Chinese have over us qui lows when we
first started working here after lunch
we couldn't really get anyone's
attention eventually we can't learn
everyone's just sleeping at that time of
day that said we embraced it very
quickly what is your preferred sleeping
apparatus I'm pretty Spartan so either
on the desk or under the desk with a bit
of bubble wrap for a pillow is good
[Music]
Luke is just one of many entrepreneurs
who come to get their gear made in
Shenzhen
there's a flourishing scene here for
hardware startups that want to move fast
and make things many of them can be
found here at a startup incubator called
hax the idea here is simple help
startups build a prototype then connect
them with factories that can start
cranking out their products by the
thousands take Jamie here an affable
chap who's part of a British startup
called cars we make a ski coach so
effectively it's like insert you put
into a ski booth and it teaches you how
to speed better so you get like
real-time feedback through headphones
like that was a bad turn that was a bad
turn that was a better time you have one
here so yeah these are motion sensors
that's spot-on motion sensing crazy like
many startups here carve began life is a
humble Kickstarter campaign now just a
couple of years later they're pumping
out 5,000 units of their product every
month do you think you could have
brought something like this to life for
the UK if you'd have been accepted by an
incubator there right now that you've
been here you see it anew yeah world I
guess I think it kind of depends a
little bit on how much of a shoestring
you're on Darren shinjae and it's so
much cheaper in many different
categories cheaper like in the product
development phase to get different
materials 3d printed or machined you get
it here for kind of half the cost and
twice as fast yeah and sometimes seven
times as fast to get a feel for that
high speed energy I hop across the
street with Jamie to the famed washing
Bay markets yeah so this is the biggest
electronics market in the world probably
they're an important resource for the
young entrepreneurs here
and a fantastic place to get your senses
overloaded walk through the market it's
like bang yeah they know like okay this
is where factories have come to display
their wares to potential buyers who is
me and I know all the other people here
kind of a storefront for factories okay
and if I make smartphones or TVs or
anything like that I got kind of coming
to see you want to find a manufacturer
you come took watch I'm Bay it's also a
great place to find that missing part
for your prototype
which is why you run into other crews
from hacks roaming the aisles find some
screws drinks
have you tried there's a spring woman
out the front as well of you one one
just on the left as you go the fact that
I can get a component in like an hour is
like absolute phenomenal that's like
baddest engine speed yeah that's why
we're here
[Applause]
here's how shenzhen works you put up a
dam things are going well here's
skyscrapers and then you put up another
one right next to it because you can and
then to really drive the point home you
do all of this next to a metallurgic
marvel of a stadium we're talking about
a boom town the likes of which the world
has never seen before
[Applause]
and things are just getting started
because inside the big stadium is the
real action
[Music]
it's a scene of smarts creativity and
hustle being collectively main life
[Music]
it doesn't look pretty it doesn't smell
great it might even be inhumane but all
of this is aimed at making China the
dominant technology force of the future
[Music]
and Silicon Valley should be very very
afraid
welcome friends to Robo masters
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a robotics competition that
draws in hundreds of engineering
students from around the world as you'll
soon see I don't really understand the
intricacies of the games but the gist is
that you build some robots choosing from
six different types like the engineer
which heals other BOTS or the hero which
does extra damage then you put them in a
stadium and have them fire plastic
bullets at each other to score points
it's fun for the whole family
if your family is a bunch of insanely
competitive gearheads
[Applause]
[Music]
four contestants this can be an intense
experience what's your life been like
for the last week the average baking
time there's like three hours how do you
do it every day and keep doing that for
weeks it's crazy
once these kids arrive for the
competition they basically don't leave
the stadium for two weeks and fighting
robot battle after robot battle takes
its toll when was the last time you had
something to eat yesterday games it is
but it's all worth it
because the reward if you're lucky is a
job a DJ I the sponsors of the
competition in the world's top maker of
drone
if you're a talented young roboticist
coming here to Shenzhen to work at DJI
is the dream so the stakes are high
there are plenty of Chinese tech
companies that produce nothing but cheap
knockoffs DJI is not one of them the
company was started in 2006 by a college
student named Frank Wang he made
components for drone hobbyists and then
decided to go ahead and make a full-on
drone Empire I think the core value of
DJ is we're always trying to innovate
something new for example when we create
a drone they are actually no flying
camera we created this concept of flying
camera that's basically true DJ eyes
first runaway hit the Phantom brought
camera drones to the masses for the
first time in 2012 since then they've
made bigger drones smaller drones teeny
tiny drones and some specialty ones like
this crop dusting drum
all its products have sold well most of
its major competitors have flown away in
tears the company rakes in billions of
dollars a year and has thousands of
employees all over the world and now
they want to pay it forward our founder
after DJI become a love is successful
yeah little bit yeah he started to think
that it's time to host his own robotics
competition we want engineers to be
recognized as Superstars and as this
competition we hope it becomes a popular
and the people and being inspired by
this engineer's it's not just the
competition itself there's also a Robo
masters documentary a Robo masters
reality show then even a Robo masters
anime with this media blitz DJI hopes to
foster a new generation of innovative
engineers who can then join the drone
Empire and make it even stronger or
maybe start the next DJI
in other words what we have here is less
of a friendly little robot fest and more
of a plan for world domination
looks like it's up to me to sabotage
this thing does that make me seem
scarier I've managed to infiltrate this
team from Joe Chong University this is
almost too easy we're going up against
the University of Washington Chinese
teams usually destroy American Knights
but my incompetence should even up the
odds you guys don't shoot me okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
prepare your teas let the robo slaughter
begin
[Music]
now what am I gonna try to do where am I
going after the games don't leave me
are we read or blue are we winning how
come nobody's talking
[Music]
we win yes
I do it I couldn't really tell what was
happening was it close so we kicked your
ass thank you I'm sorry America I tried
a few days later I returned to the
stadium to witness the final round of
competition it's South China University
of Technology vs. China's Northeastern
University
the winners will take home tens of
thousands of dollars the respect of
their fellow nerds and most likely a job
offer from DJI for another up-and-coming
company
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
the future drone makers of the PRC
[Music]
there's no disputing that Schengen has
become one of the most important places
in the world of tech nowhere else has
quite as potent a combination of techno
how cheap manufacturing costs and sheer
speed but it goes further than that
living in Shenzhen is in many ways like
living in the future but not necessarily
a utopian future more like the other
kind consider zoiy zoiy operates a
factory much like any other in Shenzhen
they make cheap smartphones and other
electronics like other top manufacturers
they've built a complex where workers
can live right beside the factory line
work around the clock for a couple of
years and hopefully buy a better life
for their families back home
the factories here are clean and the
work is precise but things are changing
quickly in a way that does not favor the
common man and woman all the rest of
these lines are stops by about 80 people
but right here there's new machines
coming on lines that are gonna build a
smartphone and robot the end goal of
something like this is to get the
quality of the product higher to bring
costs down from West Labor and
ultimately to keep China as the
manufacturing hub of the world and fend
off low price competition for places
like Southeast Asia the factory of the
future looks like this it's a closed off
loop where robots pass components among
each other and finished products pop out
at the end all those workers have been
replaced by one lonely final inspector
it's a strong sign that the future of
Shenzhen is less for these guys
and more for these guys Sallie actually
builds these automation machines itself
behind me are some of China's best and
brightest engineers hard at work
building the machines you see out on the
floor today and the ones that are coming
tomorrow that are going to automate the
entire factory life nowhere will face
more turmoil than Shenzhen as the robots
rise and send millions of workers to the
unemployment line
[Music]
but it's not just the working class
that's facing a dark future there are
dystopian innovations that seem to touch
every facet of life here I ran into one
example of this while attempting to
rehydrate after some investigation I
discover what's going on here and it has
to do with these things QR codes you
know the drill you scan the code and
something pops up on your phone it's
like a promotion or discount America
laughs these things off years ago but
here they run the entire economy cash
and credit cards are history
instead you scan QR codes to pay for
everything
restaurants groceries even buskers
[Music]
on the surface this is all good it's the
easy convenient mobile payment system of
the future but there's also a dark side
the Chinese government can peer into the
two dominant payment systems Ali pay and
WeChat as it sees fit it's already
started tracking behavior as part of a
plan to rank citizens and measure how
good and obedient they are
the tech revolution may have brought
prosperity to shenzhen but it's also
brought more and more insidious
intrusions into people's lives to dig
deeper into life under the Chinese deep
state I've assembled a team of
extraordinary foreigners who work at
tech startups in Shenzhen hopefully a
few beers will encourage them to open up
about their thought crimes living in a
very tightly regulated communist country
does that bother you or you don't like
the presumption at least that I got
before I came from Australia you sort of
like moving its are sort of like a
militarized state kind of thing like
things gonna be really intense but like
you take a beer as I walk down the road
hang out in the park fine
yeah do that back in my hometown
Australia like straight to the compound
but then play spikeball on the grass so
yeah and then all of a sudden the cops
go in struggling you guys you jaywalked
and you had facial recognition got this
yes oh also I was jaywalking and Nanshan
and all of a sudden I got a fighting to
my Witcher was he interested it was it
was about 220 20 seconds after I have
money in my Barrett it just went
straight out and this is just people say
you didn't his came straight out feed
him too right now that was includes
crazy it's true
try to jaywalk in certain parts of
Shenzhen and the government's facial
recognition will spot you
there's even a board of shame showing
the faces of recent offenders I'm
surprised and very very worried that
they have your face in the face
recognize like face recognition you have
everyone's though I mean when you go
exactly told in the system they know
where you are so Airy it gets even
scarier because big brother is watching
what you do online to most of the
websites we know and love are blocked in
China replaced with Chinese equivalents
that the government can monitor a sort
of Mirror Universe Internet
I asked my friend Diane a chené chené
native to help break this down
appropriately enough she took me to this
restaurant staffed entirely by robots
that's some gnarly looking chick who's
that chick is robot food want you to
help you out with one thing so if I sort
of call out a u.s. tech company can you
tell me the Chinese equivalent goal
would be at Amazon it's like both JD
calm and also how about okay and YouTube
your core Yoho I see year Facebook face
away of the widget
WeChat yeah yeah do you feel like you're
in universe all the online stuff is such
a big part of all our lives and and it
seems like China has created its own
right world yeah that's definitely like
that but like I said for like Instagram
I was surprised to see even in stock
when I got banned from China but all the
young people there they're still go yeah
it turns out it is possible to access
the freedom-loving internet here via
what's called a VPN an alternate
internet connection that bypasses the
governments blocks and you don't get in
trouble if they see that your other VPN
long time but personal use I don't think
that's like yeah future will be
interesting for how old it's a different
world like collaborating together yeah
and then definitely the young generation
there during are like just oh I'm
satisfied just kind of stay inside ok
yeah they're more curious
I came to Shenzhen hoping to find some
kind of ground truth a clear picture of
what China's growing tech prowess will
mean for the rest of us honestly though
I'm as confused as ever the city is full
of energy desire and creativity but
exactly how those traits are channeled
in the years ahead
remains an open question my hope is that
the best parts of our human nature get a
chance to thrive and that 1984 can wait
a few more decades to arrive and on that
note I leave you with this dashboard dog
because it's obviously good and pure and
very happy
[Music]
thanks for watching and if you want to
see more hello world click on the link
to subscribe